When people have me on, they expect me to,
to make the case for essential workers.
And of course I do because everybody understands that case.
And when dirty jobs went on, nobody was making that case.
So I felt special and I felt like, uh, you know, iconic class out there saying,
Hey, don't forget about this one. And this one and this one right now,
while I still hold them in the absolute, highest esteem,
I'm amazed at how we've taken 35 million people and
deemed them on essential.
That to me is something I reckon we're going to look back on with
great linguistic embarrassment.
The main question that I think I wanted to ask you that I think will sort of
frame everything else we're going to talk about is that there seems to be a
narrative out there from a certain set of people, um, that, that it's like, Oh,
going back to work, it's just too risky. And no one really wants to work anyway.
And you know, AOC had some version of this sort of thing. Like only in America,
would we value work so high.
And as a guy that I've seen do the craziest jobs, you know,
where you're stepping in and your hands in this animal, the bats,
electricity water,
you can give me 10 other examples of the crazy things that you've had people.
Do you work with people who are do this for a living?
Can you just talk about just broadly,
like the importance of work relative to finding purpose in life,
relative to just setting up the rest of the things that you want out of life?
Because that actually is one of the things that I'm most worried about right now
that as we sort of give away our day-to-day lives,
that we're going to forget that work is important.
Not I'm not talking about slavery, but I'm just talking about the,
getting up with something to do, because it makes you some money.
So you can do everything else with your life that you want to do.
So it's the frog in the boiling water. Uh, I share your fear.
It's not going to happen like a light switch though. Um, what's the old poem,
not, not with a bang,
but a whimper and the way it will happen here is people
like AOC and others who genuinely are maybe not so genuinely
believe that work is fundamentally.
Another expression for drudgery are going to make those points.
They're going,
they're going to reduce it to something that's purely transactional.
That's that's the first step.
And if you only look at what you do as a means
to make money, then I, then, then,
then you're not an interesting person. Okay. It's just,
it's such a one dimensional way to look at something that
should in my view. And oftentimes does define us,
you know, it's our work. It's a, it's,
it's the thing we choose to do with the most conscious
chunk of our life.
And so to reduce it to a paycheck is dumb.
Obviously there's a giant transactional element involved in it,
but there's so much more dirty jobs happened because,
because I couldn't follow in my grandfather's footsteps,
which I very much wanted to do.
My pop was a guy who could build up a house without a blueprint.
You only went to the seventh grade,
but he had the chip right in his brain that he could take your watch apart and
put it back together, blindfolded. He could, he could build a house.
He could run pipe. He was a master electrician, steam fitter pipe,
fitter mechanic architect, all of that. Well,
he was heroic in his youth in his time
for those things today, he'd be, uh,
Mr. Cellophane, you know, he's transparent.
And so many of those trades, so many of those,
those vocations have fallen, uh, into,
into this gap between blue and white collar. They've, they've lost their luster.
And we're simply not really gobsmacked the way we used to be about the
miracle of modern plumbing or the miracle.
What happens when you flick the switch and the light comes on. So,
so dirty jobs was meant to be the attribute to my grandfather
initially. And it was,
and then it became a rumination on essential work,
which is interesting, right? Because obviously the headlines have, have,
have caught up with that. And that's really been my great,
good fortune over the years, I do average shows with low production value,
but big themes. And I stick with those themes.
And every couple of years, the headlines will catch up with them dirty jobs.
And the people we featured became weirdly relevant when the economy crashed in
2009 and it's become weirdly relevant this month,
I've been on every talk show. There is to talk about essential work.
And it's funny. I'll tell you what happens. I mean, look, there's a,
there's a poster I keep, but all my Walter reminded me.
I put a pig on a pedestal many years ago for a lot of. And um,
when people have me on,
they expect me to make the case for essential workers.
And of course I do because everybody understands that case.
Now when dirty jobs went on, nobody was making that case.
So I felt special and I felt like, uh, you know, iconic class out there saying,
Hey, don't forget about this one. And this one and this one right now,
while still hold them in the absolute highest esteem.
I'm amazed at how we've taken 35 million people
and deemed them on essential.
That to me is something I reckon we're going to look back on with
great linguistic embarrassment, because.
That, that that's exactly what I wanted to ask you next. So continue, continue.
No, it's your turn. I just realized.
That was the question really like when, once we say to 35 million people,
you're not essential, it's not just about the job that they do. It's,
it's the message that's getting across to their lives,
which in some ways I actually think in some ways,
if they can get through it and then rethink what they do,
maybe there is something else they want to do.
But I don't think that's the message that most people are going to get.
I think we're going to leave people with some sort of existential crisis.
We're doing it. It's part of the grieving process. I was saying earlier,
people are coming to terms with the fact that their vocations don't matter in
the eyes of virtually everyone who has a show to host
because in our,
in our well-intended enthusiasm to celebrate the essential workers,
we've done a thing we always do with the language. And I am,
I am not a politically correct person. I at least I try not to be,
but language does matter a lot. And you know,
in my own foundation, when I feel most comfortably in my own lane,
I talk about education and the skilled trades and higher
education is a turn of phrase that has become inculpated.
And when we talk about the importance of higher education, well,
who would doubt it? Of course,
we need big people with big brains doing important work, but what,
what does higher education imply?
If not the existence of many forms of lower education,
subordinate education.
So the language bakes in a terrible kind of analysis.
If you don't get a four year degree,
if you don't buy into the idea that the most expensive path is the best path for
the most people, then you wind up doing something.
They don't call it lower education, because that would just be crazy,
but they call it alternative. Ah, we have some alternatives for you, Dave,
maybe you'd like it over here in a trade school,
or perhaps you'd be comfortable over here in a community college or in a
fellowship or an apprenticeship.
So we did that in education and the unintended consequences are breathtaking.
We're doing it now with the very heart of people's
identities and we're doing it around the simple word.
We're not meaning to do it, but you watch it's,
it's going to come back over the net with a lot of top spend.
People are already off about it. I just don't think they quite understand why.
Yeah.
Let's actually back up for a second and talk about your foundation a little bit,
because everything saying right now,
I think does get to a trend that I've been seeing for a while,
which is I've had so many guests to come from academia. And you know,
so much of our national conversation is about outrage culture and cancel
culture. And what's happening at colleges.
And now because of YouTube average people.
And I mean that in the best sense of average, all of us can,
can watch incredible thinkers, give lectures.
You can watch Jordan Peterson lectures on YouTube for free,
and maybe get more information from that. Then you can,
from a semester that you're paying 25 grand for,
so talk about your foundation and, and sort of,
can you just relate that a little bit to what you see happening with higher ed
relative to, if you have a trade right now,
it's like you are essential again, in the best sense of essential. That's not,
I'm not putting down the nonessential.
Maybe we can come up with a better word for it right now.
Well, we should because everything has a season.
And part of the reason we're locked in this endless feedback loop of nonsense is
because we're in love with cookie cutter advice.
And so we dispense it with certainty and this is what
politicians do to be elected. They have to, they,
they have to say the thing that's going to resonate with the most people.
And so they wind up,
they wind up retrenching to bromide and platitudes and tropes.
That's what safety first is.
We're more honest and thoughtful conversations about lifestyles instead of
nonstop yelling, checkout our lifestyle playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.